welcome to this video playing oj three
so what could apply a camera lets the
Queens gambit accepted yeah okay I am if
I was a very ambitious line which I
don't really know that well wow really
that played d5 know what are you going
to do Knight takes e4 maybe now that
it's hard to believe really
hmm that's cute I go before here takes
things now this is the usual problem
with this night on a five it's almost
wrapped and maybe he can okay maybe you
can play you sexy or something like that
defending look takes a five with bishop
yeah yeah this could actually be a move
but what if I do Bishop d2 here is he
going to play b6 wow what a weird we at
position yet taking it should be for
Bishop to Bishop takes a five Bishop
takes a five looks really strange and
Bishop d2 here he must play be six year
hmm and after be six what am I going to
do the trick it's got Bishop d7 195
attending Bishop b5 Wow yeah this is the
kind of position where you would love to
have a couple of minutes on your hand to
really figure out what's going on but ok
and I need to to move yeah Bishop b5 is
maybe just see just moving the king
maybe Jim
check yeah maybe maybe you can just move
the kingdom hmm so probably 95 wasn't
very precise okay well this is not
really what I wanted to do 985 phone via
taxi five so okay yeah not ideal far
from that and don't know if i was
hanging but at least he's got this
development issues okay i need to get
need to play for my my development edge
ok i could have taken a seven but i
wanted to get I mean this is just a pawn
I don't really know if I should take it
okay that is the kind of the kind of
opening where you know that the computer
afterwards we'll show you how he could
have punished him but it's um it's
tricky with the limited time of this
limb okay takes maybe maybe just develop
him
John I think you should probably just
take 1 D 2 and I don't know play a five
or something like that looks like i
don't know maybe maybe I still have some
compensation it's probably not enough
but maybe it's playable well he's got
the only issue is this a box didn't look
other than that black is perfectly okay
maybe you can even just just play Queen
edge form something like that
it's taking time this is so this is nice
at least a from practical point of view
we can take here come to bonds maybe i
get d 5 ok take it the show the ship to
edge form
hmm maybe I can get default somehow okay
at least opposite colored bishops but he
is probably able to get the King out
ok I've got one one point Luke f3 is an
idea ok I've made some substantial
progress here at least it's not lost
anymore check ok time morning tending
rookie seven
takes Queen takes wins the rook but he's
it's his knees okay if I go here he's
really going to go to h adium well
that's sick that this is working as a
bit sick Jan came and then he's got this
check here right ok but I go here I it's
got Queen f1 that's check Queen f1 now
thats that's the one the one move that
he really needs other than that you
would be lost really check I can
actually take the room as well check can
just take the rook
it's somehow it seems that he is not
seeing this right maybe it's got
something else I don't know Luke h2 is
not winning yeah what Bishop e7 is very
simple check Wow check check check check
check check check check check check yeah
it is whoops it was a draw it's the list
of course you can always sacrifice check
yeah okay game yeah could have just
taken the rook I mean this was yeah but
sometimes you just don't see the the
easiest wins here like I can just take
the book here also has a mac computer
says there's a mate where is it yeah
Bishop e7 in fact is the mate because
the tech is is just too overwhelming
yeah I can't like to really know what
was going on in this opening ok so Queen
a force winning ok then this is right
here I mean it's really clear that this
is not playable I mean this looks
completely crazy but ok before was not
what's not really refuting it it seems
to be good for white according to the
comb but it's not winning yeah this is
winning ok Bishop t2 here hmm yeah
sometimes sometimes like you has
technical tricks in this types of
positions but yes simply nothing guys
I'm just I'm just going to to pick up
everything here I mean it's it's not
even if yet whatwhat's blacks movie I my
take on c4 and just attack without even
having sacrificed anything okay but
before let's let's check this storm and
now before I before first yeah this is
probably true why I went here and
overlooked Bishop d6 so before for us is
also good for white check with this ok
this looks completely sick so needs to
go here again just ok just taking is
good ok yeah this is a very good
positional compensation alone this is
this will lead to the problems and if
you go here
you're just taking and then just play
this position what is a pawn down but I
mean these pieces are really clumsy de
place and have queen bee three bishops
III it's just a big attack look at a c6
this is this is how its needs to be
played here I'm already in some kind of
trouble check at least from a practical
point of view it's um it's tricky yeah I
don't know I cancelled here there's
always some development but probably
never never really enough yeah he
allowed many things here around here I
think I'm perfectly okay I've got the
check good activity no no real problem
of course I I didn't see that you can
just play King edge ATM something like
that is probably okay it's really
opposite colored bishops with the I mean
the position is so open they're probably
we get heavy pieces exchanged and then
it's relatively easy draw with the
opposite colored bishops just being a
pawn down okay crazy stuff thanks for
watching